The three equations we have here in black boxes are the inverses of the
equations we started out with. I've written out the steps to find each of these
inverse functions, and there's one important thing I'd like you to notice. To
indicate the point at which we switch from modifying the original function to
modifying the inverse function, I changed colors. So the first two steps of
each equation are still working with the original functions. Then at the point
where we switch the position of x and y, we've changed the equation to be the
inverse function. All the work with the inverse function, for each of these, is
in purple. The actual steps that we've gone through when modifying either the
original function or the inverse function are pretty standard algebra. They're
things that you learned about very early on in this course. Why don't we take a
look at this middle one just as an example. As we discussed earlier, the first
thing that I did was switch from calling this g of x to calling it y. Just so
that when we're moving things around, it's easy to tell what that variable
actually is. We won't get it confused with anything. Then, to change from the
original function to the inverse, I just switch this box of x and y. Since that
if y equals 1 quarter times x minus 9, we have x equals 1 quarter times y minus
9. From there, I multiply both sides by 4, and then I'll add a 9 to both sides
to get y by itself. Since I want g inverse of x on the left side of the
equation, since that's our standard function notation, I just took one extra
step to switch the sides of the equation. So that y was on the left instead of
on the right. That gave us a final answer of g inverse of x equals 4x plus 9.
The other two answers we ended up with were f inverse of x equals x minus 1.
And h inverse of x equals the cube root of x. Now instead of writing cube root
x, you could of course have written x to the 1 3rd power instead. Either way is
correct. I hope this extra practice with inverse functions helped you feel a
bit more comfortable with the process we have to go through for finding them.